The coronavirus pandemic has remapped everyone’s worlds.
How has that looked for you?
CityLab is an online news magazine about urban
life and places that matter.
In April, we asked readers to share homemade
maps
depicting how the pandemic has changed their lives.
Within a month, we’d received more than
300 submissions from around the world.
Using pencil, watercolors, clay, found objects
and many other media, readers mapped a rich
spectrum of perspectives, experiences, hopes,
and frustrations - from the places they fled,
to the people they miss, to the nature, neighbors,
and secret spots of solace they cling to.
Some showed the ways their home lives had been hemmed in
and rearranged by the virus outside.
Many readers infused their maps with humor,
like this one sheltering in her apartment
in New Delhi.
And this one, from California, of a relationship
tested by extreme mundanity.
With distractions in scarce supply, several
readers turned to fantasy for inspiration.
From Spain to Vietnam to Canada, neighborhoods
were perceived in new ways.
“The lockdown has made people scatter from
the streets, and with them cars and noise,”
wrote one reader about her map of silence
in surrounding Bilbao.
“I found myself listening more intently
as I walked and forming new dictionaries of
sound in my head,” wrote another person
about the sounds of Cambridge, Massachusetts.
A routine walk focused the attention of this
reader in Austin, Texas, who wrote:
"I've become cognizant of the tiny details in people's yards that reveal things about their lives.”
But for a lot of people, the contrast between
inside and outside felt really dark.
Many maps were laced with stress and anxiety.
Lonely landscapes were marked with memories
of social contact.
With school closures and travel restrictions
upending their lives, several readers wished
they could be somewhere other than where they
were, like this college student
unhappy to be back at home.
And this Italian expatriate in the U.S., missing
her family in Bergamo.
“Even if the pandemic has made physical
distances more painful, in my heart, my beloved
worlds are even closer.”
Some envisioned a better world, like a Miami
resident who thinks more public transit could
reconnect the city once lockdowns lift.
Access to nature seemed to make all the difference.
In Sydney, Australia, a reader found herself
looking closer at the trees on her block.
In the U.K., a writer sketched what she called
“a beautiful old canyon near our house that
looks like a lost world.”
Though each submission was unique, put together
these maps show how the emotional experiences
of the coronavirus pandemic have been shared
by people all over the world.
As economies reopen and a wave of protests
fill formerly empty streets, public and private
spaces are shifting once again, as societies
struggle to balance the sweeping impacts of
the pandemic and a massive call to address
systemic racism and injustice.
As a powerful medium for revealing our relationships
to place, these maps serve as a reminder of
the ways we are still connected - especially
through times of upheaval,
and as new futures are forged.